going out to milwaukee have a
conversation there with tasha tasha good
afternoon how can ken and i help
hi i'm calling because i have only been
married about three months and i
pulled our credit reports and i found
that my
new husband has almost a hundred
thousand dollars in
black child support that he owns oh dear
and i don't know what to do all right
i pulled our credit reports because i
wanted to get on
the baby steps and first to buy a house
and you know do all the
regular things that people do and
um i don't know i i i'm stumped with
this i have no idea where to begin
my goodness does he know that you know
this yet
um i think he i'm sure he does
because he knows i have the credit
report
but he hasn't said anything oh my god i
don't even know what to say to him
all right so here's what we got to do
that music means we've got to go to a
commercial break
uh but we're going to put you on hold
hang with us tasha when we come back
we're going to dive into this
before the break we were on the phone
with tasha and tasha
um was informing us that
recently she was blessed to get married
but unfortunately she found out that her
husband
owes about a hundred thousand dollars in
back child support and so we didn't want
to rush through that call we asked her
to hold on
uh so we can really dive into deep
deeper here
and so we can help her out so uh tasha i
got a quick question for you that i'm
curious
um actually a couple of questions number
one uh
was this within the last 24 hours was
this recently that you pulled the credit
report
and you had um and you found this
information out
and then two is
did he mention this at all did he try to
hint to this at all before you
all got married uh that hey you know i
owe some child support or i'm paying
child support
well i the credit report i did get
within the last 24 hours it was
yesterday
um i knew he owed tone support but i was
under the impression
it was nowhere near this amount
and that it a portion of it had been
forgiven
but apparently that is not the case
okay all right so i was under the
impression that it was
about 20 or 30 and that
he had paid um 75
of it and that the other portion was
forgiven
do you guys have uh joint banking
we do not that's a problem and
and that's a real problem because this
is why
you didn't know about it even any sooner
than this uh and the other problem is is
you told us before we went to the break
you guys haven't even spoken about it
so i asked you if he knew that you knew
and you said
well he must because he knows that i
pulled the credit report
so that means if that's in fact the case
you guys are walking around avoiding
each other the tension's got to be so
thick you can cut it with a knife am i
right
well
okay it doesn't matter he knows there's
something wrong
yeah because he's asked me several times
today yeah you're showing it
are you okay yeah and what have you said
really nothing nice okay all right tasha
yeah tasha this is uh when he comes home
from work
you guys it's it's everything is on hold
and you got to sit down and share with
him what you know
and we've got several things going on
here
okay um he has lied to you
and and you aren't
addressing this right away you're kind
of trying to sit on this a little bit
this is we got to get this out in the
open it is what it is now
and you weren't told the truth and you
guys have separate bank accounts
which means you guys are not truly
unified and
the reason i'm bringing up the separate
bank accounts is because when you sit
down with him and talk about all the
relationship piece and the line
there's also the financial part to this
so the state of wisconsin every state
has laws on paying child support
and so when a judge lays down a decree
as he has in this situation saying
you owe this child support on a monthly
basis and now it's been racked up to 100
and if it's
not paid in a timely manner then they
can
they can do a lot of things uh interest
which is gonna make the hundred thousand
bigger than it already is it's gonna
keep growing
like a monster underneath the stairs it
is then
uh tax refunds can be garnished and
withheld if you will
pay i mean this thing is a really really
nasty thing that's got to be dealt with
it can't be
swept underneath the rug anymore and so
it's time to get this all out
and i will tell you that marriage
counseling is a piece of this as well
we've got to get this fixed we're three
months in
and this affects you financially as well
and and here's the thing tasha i think
when you
when you sit down and talk to you to
your husband um
i was trying to find a way to just to
find clarity
uh because here's the concern that i
have okay whether it's a hundred
thousand or ten thousand or five
thousand
um it's you're not supporting your own
child
and then that's to me that's more
important than a hundred thousand
dollars that you don't want to support
the human being that you brought into
this to this world
and so i would have that conversation
before the money because
do you two plan on having kids
no we do not we both
i'm older well we're both older okay and
um well i guess not much older but we
have adult children
yeah i'm i agree with ken i agree with
ken you two have to get to the bottom of
this but
also i mean i'm not a woman
so i can't say this but i'm like i want
to know why if that was my brother why
are you not taking care
of your responsibilities because now
that makes me concerned about
us together is your husband gainfully
employed or is he just scraping by
yeah we both are employed um
and make about 35 to 40
000 a year both of you together or
individually
each individually okay so let's call it
75
to 80 000 somewhere in that range
uh he's gonna have to deal with this and
you're gonna have to make him deal with
this but i'm gonna tell you where it
starts
it starts with no longer are we having
separate bank accounts when there's no
more secrets
he has violated trust with you now i do
believe that he can be forgiven i think
he should be forgiven
but that's if he repents and acts in a
way that would uh
allow you to truly give full forgiveness
but we've got to move forward
on this and and he's got to take care of
this and he's got to step up big time
uh and and you've got to lay it out
there and say we're not just going to
treat this like
you know the dirty little secret that
nobody wants to talk about
this is a problem you have been
dishonest with me
you have broken trust and you've got to
earn that back
and you got to take care of business you
got to you got to
you got to get with the courts you got
to figure something out because there's
a reason why he's 100 grand behind
yeah right yeah that i don't know what
it is and we don't have time to unpack
that
but i also think marriage counseling i i
if i were you i would push him
really really intensely because you guys
need to get with a professional
and deal with some of the stuff that's
going on here that's put him
in a place where he feels like he has to
be dishonest about it